so the European Space Agency is sending
its first ever dedicated mission to
Jupiter here are a few key facts about
that mission so juice as its known will
launch from French Guiana on an Ariane 5
rocket it's going to cost around 700
million pounds over the lifetime of its
Mission and it's not going to take a
very direct route to get there it has to
go twice around the earth and once
around Venus to get enough speed to
travel all the way out to the gas giant
planet Jupiter and when it gets there
its primary focus although we'll study
Jupiter itself more importantly it's big
icy moons Ganymede Callisto and Europa
because they are believed to be covered
in an icy surface of water beneath which
they could be liquid oceans of water if
there's going to be life anywhere in our
solar system the IC moons of Jupiter is
probably where it's going to be and even
if they're not it will give us profound
insights into how gas giants planets
form in our solar system and elsewhere
in our galaxy it's going to do a lot of
very detailed studies this lab in Essex
but Teledyne are the ones who develop
the sensor that's going to be in the
camera of the juice Mission its eyes on
the planet and those all-important icy
moons
but we're gonna have to wait quite a
long time to see what this census is
it's an eight-year Mission just to get
there we probably won't get images until
2031 but the hope is they'll be worth
the wait